Field when he was,
he did some of the early cycle surgery
for epilepsy because it intractable
epilepsy.
Sometimes the only thing
to do is radical surgery,
like a corpus.
He caught the Corpus callosum for example.
So that the,
you know,
the,
the electrical storm so to speak,
can't transmit across the hemispheres
and the whole brain won't be effective.
So,
but while he was doing that,
he used a little electrode to map out the
surface of the brain and he mapped out
the motor strip,
which is just behind
the prefrontal cortex.
And then the sensory strip,
which is just behind that to find
out how the body representatives are,
the brain represents the body.
And basically what he showed
was that on the motor strip,
you know,
you're,
the thumb has as much
representation as your whole trunk.
So basically your thumb is as
smart from a motoric perspective,
smarter than you from here to here,
you know,
well try picking up
something with your back,
you know,
and you'll figure out exactly why that is.
And the thumb basically has almost as
much representation as the rest of the
hand.
But the hands are like gigantic balloons,
you know,
and the arms are a little
skinny sticks here,
here,
theater fairly highly
represented,
especially in the sensory
cortex because you know,
you gotta be careful about what you,
what you step on.
And one of the things that's
very interesting about
the representation of the
feet on the sensory strip is that it's
right beside the representation of the
Genitalia.
And so there's cross costs.
And so some of you are pretty
into foot massages and that's why,
you know,
so it's,
it's,
it's a consequence of the overlap.
Now why that overlap is there,
I don't know exactly,
you know,
maybe maybe the brain
had organized itself.
So particularly sensitive surfaces.
We're taking advantage of the same tissue,
something like that.
But you know,
it's an interesting case of,
it's like synesthesia and sent in a sense,
it's like sensory synesthesia.
So,
um,
as far as your brain's concerned,
your all hands and your hands are almost
all thumb and you're quite a bit of
feet and your lips are
massive and so is your tongue.
And your face is very
highly represented too.
So basically as far as your
brain is concerned with
regards to sensory input and
motor output,
you're this huge face with great big
lips and tongue and you have massive
balloon like hands and your
feet are pretty big too.
And there's a fair bit of sensory
representation for the Genitalia as well.
And then the body's hardly there at all.
So,
so that's kind of what
a human being is like,
right?
We're all thumbs in hands and we talk
about what we do with our thumbs and hands
all the time when we take things apart
with them and we put them together and
then we tell everybody
else how we're doing that.
And that's basically a human being.
And when you're thinking about the
difference between human beings and highly
encephalitis mammals
like dolphins and whales,
because people have claimed that
dolphins and whales are extraordinarily
intelligent.
And you know,
dolphins don't seem
particularly simple minded,
but look at the things they're in.
Like if they're in these
test tube shaped bodies,
what are they gonna do?
Flip sand up into buildings?
It's like they can't manage that.
And so the embodied the,
the manner in which their nervous
system is embodied turns out to be
extraordinarily important when you're
trying to understand something like the
relationship between cortical tissue,
mass and intelligence,
you can't just think about mind as
something that's floating like a soul in
space.
If it isn't stuck in
something that you can use,
it's not particularly good for anything
or anything that human beings would
regard as particularly intelligence.